abone ol
bu
Şehrimize bankamızda sayısız uygarlığın
izlerini görüyoruz
etrafımızda gördüğümüz her şey yaşadığı
bir daha İyiler buralara eski sağladılar
doğumlu kullanıyordu tanıyorum öğrenin
kızarması için
bir parayı
eski
paylaşıyoruz o
[Müzik]
abone ol
bir yıldız ve gezegenlerin eski
insanların
üzerine Biz var da yok Bunlar
nasıl zayıflar var Örneğin bile bir süre
sonra Önceden tahmin ettiği yazıyordu
özelliklerimizi ihbar huzurlu olduğunu
biliyoruz
Bu yıl başta doldu Ben sizin olduğunuz
şiirlerini takımımız ağlamazmış
bu
[Müzik]
biri yazılım olmayanlar önemli geldik
ayrıntıyı Enes partimizin boyundadır
uzanan oluyor bir kabaklar bir kolye
doğru benzer şekilde
sevgi üzerine güneşin var etmesin denmiş
şohal o
[Müzik]
de
tam
bilmiyoruz
ama bu balığımızı dünyadaki en iyisi
olduğunda yeni masallar
en iyi devam edecek bir şey sevgiyle
kalsın Boşandığı eşi
Evet bu da
[Müzik]
yer alan Kılavuzlu
sağlamamış
vardı Ve kutsal alanı Aslında kanallarda
başladı şişlerle dağılmış şekilde
duyurdu ve tam ortada Kral Pek uzun
tüylü yumurta başlandı oluşmuş güçsüz
oldu Onun için güzel yerler var
[Müzik]
bu ve buradayım karşılığında
değil
asallık yerleşim
yapılmıştır üzerinde olduğumuz daha iyi
Yıldız oluyor Yıldızlar düşüneceğim
işaretlenmiş bu
[Müzik]
o
bölgeye
bugün
örnek oluyorsunuz
yani o
[Müzik]
bu
göre bu
Gökhan hızlı Oh buz
tanımadığım arasındaki
sorunlu bir
şaşırdı 4'ü
[Müzik]
Bu
güneş
birisidir ve
[Müzik]
veya
oldu Tanrım
söylediğinde ona o
[Müzik]
yeni
başlayan yürüyüş olduğunu abi
bizim o
halde
[Müzik]
siz olacak
Daha sonra o
[Müzik]
o
ilk defa
[Müzik]
98 yıl olmuş
düşmüş olduğu tarihi ve
bu
[Müzik]
konu olan
gezegenler gerçekten hazırladığımız
yüzüyorlar kadar bu bir araya geldi
o yüzden olabilir Bunu göreceksiniz dedi
daha çalışmalar üç tane tarihi bize
gösteriyor
[Müzik]
Bu tarih-i
çok
[Müzik]
güzel olduğunu astrolojinin yandığını
dair gidiyoruz Hatta takoz oldu
yaptığını anlıyor musun
İyi
günler
Oha
yerlerde 3 Adam ailemizin azaldığı
üzerinde bir yapmıştır gerçeklerini
ilgili sağlık Dahası da var birader 19
yıl oldu uzun da kutsal aldığında
başladığı tarihte bile gezegenler
görülmüş o hali her üç tarihte bir arada
değil mi
[Müzik]
ve
Anadolu'da
zorundayım Herkes diyor Onun Dayı Eğer
sizin kadar oluşuyorsa buna
koşuyor bunu da boğazlı Kralı ı
[Müzik]
ya hu
Arkadaşlar bu
hızlı dünyadaki eski [ __ ] Çünkü dünya
üzerinde okulumuzda yapılarak Örneğin
devlet akıl anlamadım şunu dizisinde
güzel geliyor O da gelin sayfası bakalım
göster değil bu benim daha doğru
bildiğimiz dünya üzerindeki eski o
[Müzik]
ve
bunların
Türkiye yaralandığında istekleri
olduğunu Siz de sahnelerde şu anda
Türkiye'de Aslı bozulmuştur
görebileceğiniz bu
[Müzik]
da aynı şeyleri de bana kalkmış
üzerleri işareti
gösterdiğini söyleyen
Daha
[Müzik]
doğrusu belli
gösterdiği Düşünüyor bu konuları uzun
bir süre 1900 onlardan biri çeşitleri
vardır fakat yakın zamanda şehrizor ve
daha az
sayesinde
her yerde eski o
[Müzik]
oh oh be çoluk eski fotoğrafları Kültür
Merkezi
eğlencelerde ki Ayvalı Bütün bunların
uygulama incelenmesi gerekiyor çünkü o
da sadece silikon aşağıda değil bazıları
astronomi mesajını vermek üzere
buluşturduklarını önümüze hiçbir şey
değilmiş yetişkin falan var artık
hastaları kulaklık olayı bir çocuğun
Çünkü Türkiye'nin kişiliğini büyük bir
Mavi Ay
abone ol